HE'S GOTIS FOLDED,EAS SOMETHING
COURT SYSTEMT HUMBLES
EVERYONE, BRVERYONE DOWNL PL
WID OUTSIDE THE
COURTHOUSE, INS
MOMENT, SIDE THE.A, WHAT ARE YO
THE FORMERSIDENT WAS ASKEDND EN
TO THE CHAHA BEEN LED AGT
W AGAIHEN INDIDN'T EVEHO.ED STR
FLORIDA, WHEN HE
THIS IN A FEDERAL COURTROO HE HI
THAT PLEA.Y THATHIS
FICANT.
NOW THE JUDGE IS READI
ITIONS
YOU MAY REMEHAN  ACTUALLY WHAT
COMMUNICATE WITH ANYE TOITNESS
THROUGH A LAWYER.
NOW THAT COULD GETY
BECA HE'
SIXCO-CONSPIRATORS, MANY WHO
ARE STL E ASSOCIATES.E
DOCUMENTS E FACT THA
MANY PEOPLE INHICIRCLE
ARE CAUGHT UP IN THIS, THAT WILL
THINGS FROE IC TO SEE IF
ING HI A
JUROR OR
THREATEN A WITNESS OR RETALIAT
AGAINST ANYONE ELSE WHO PROVIDED
INFORMATION OR OTHERWISE
OBSTRUCT JCE
CHARGED
ITIO BUOBRUOBSTRUCTION.GHLL OF A
A FORMER
LEADOR A AGAIN
CODE AGREED E HE HAS NOW SAT ANU
SHORTLY.
LISTEN
THAT FORMET WOULD
SHOW UP IN PERSON TO
HI
ONN TRUMP'
TO USTHIS N STILL WITH HI
PR SPACE TO
TRY TOOO RE-ELECTION.
ABOUT THINGS LIKE ERENNOIN YOU L
FOLKS ON CAL
NT TO ECHO
AT VAN SAID, TO THE DEGREE I
PRESIDENT,S
IS A SOBERING
SET, AND THIS IS IS OUT OF HIS .
THINGSRE OF
THIS MOMENT AND ASS LEGAL PROC
REMBA SE
AND THOSE WORDS THAT HE S
ISSUEDTH KNOW,
HE D WITNESSES, THE
JURY, AND  I THINK
IS WHEN HIS ATTORNEYS START
S CA
TO USE HIS MEGAPHONE, SAE THINK.
'S
INTIMIDATED JACK SMI.
ITNG
E LEAVES
COURTROOM IF HSAN TRUTH
SOCIAL WHAT ECT HITOANY WAYS TH
MART YOUNO FOR H PEOPLE, TO HAV
SOMEINKN, I WOULD
IMAGINE  I
H IT' BE A GOOD O
S TURNING OUT TO BITE DIFFERENT
TH THAT IF YOUTEN TOTWORK THAT
S E E.T
EVERYBODY IT'SRO
PRESIDENT TOBUIN OFFICE.
MYSELF, I LOOK AT S, IT'G.OW T
OFFICE.
ABUSI BY RERSORWORLAYS, N
SICKING THE DODGE UMP
BI.
UMS ASTERFT
GO ALONG WITEL
THAHOW HE'S THE
VICTER HE'NOT.
COLLINS OUTSIDE COURTHOUSE.te
ABIS.
WE ARE TOLD OBVIOUATHEDGS WE EX
HERE,
PRET DETENTION.
BUT PAULA, LEARNIN
ABOUT WHAT'SPENING,
TALKED TO JUDGE CHN RSEEING THCT
WHAT THE NEXSTS ARE AND WHAT
A DATE CLD>> Reporter: THAT'GH
CHANL OU TO SEIN THE
PARTIES THERE.
SOY THE JUDGE HERE SAYS THMAGIS
RESPECOVRWARD, SHE'SCONSULTED W
2nd, ANDT ,
GIVING SPECIFIC TIMES.TH PROCED.
THEY HAVE OVER N INTOANTHE THE E
IG THE ARE T ELECTION
TALKING.
ALSO T
ep DATHEARG.
INGUST 23rd ISST DEBATE
TE. REPUBLICRI
TRUMP HAID HS .
THE IDEA THAT HELD BINURN FOE R
ON STAGE IN AN
YOU MAKE A GREATOI LOOK AT THEA
ALL THE THINGS
PRESIDENTIAL
CAS TO A HAS
DO, THS,
THERE'S SO MOVERTHR LEGAL ISSUHA
F
HAS A TRIAL SCHEDULED INJANUOT.
HE CALENDAR WHERE LE T
N TRY TOUT A TRIAL
ANYTHINGHAT DOESN'T IN ANY WAY
OVERLAP WITH SOME OF HIS
SO WE'LLES AS THPRESUMPTIVE PU
SETTLE ON.
BUT THIS THEIR
HEBEFORE T
OVEREI TRIAL UNLIKELY THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILLE TO ATTEND.
HERE IT'S INIBNIFICANTCHE CHEDU.
DELAY, DELAY, >> Reporter: YEAH.
WE'LL IFS
ON
WHO WAIDE THE M.
WE'RE LEARNING THAE S AGREED WI
AFTE IN H
MILWAUKEE.
WE DON'T EXPECT TRUMP TO ATTEND?
>> Repte YEAH.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
TIME GOING THRGHN
HIS BODYANABSOLUTE
A DIFFERENT.
HE SAT WITH CLPPEARESP
SOMETHING.
PRETRIAL WHO T
HANDED O HIS ATTO TO TH
THERE, TOM WINDH ANDN
LAUR ON MR. S SIDE.
AND THEN THEY BEGAN DISCUSSING
WHATEVERN PERHAPS THE
BA P
THERE WAIN THAT AT HE IS HANDEDI
PAPERWORK THAT APPEARS -- APPEAR
LO SLE OF --EEMED TO BE HEATEDOS
HE LOOKED AROUND THE R
THERE WERE A T WHERE HHA, HE AND
JACK SMI LOOKED AT EACH
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY MORE JACK
SMIT DIRECTION,
T THE FORMER PRESIDENT BECNTELW
OM THE ONEMIAMI,
FROM THE HEARING IMIAMI, WHERE
T SEE EACH OTHER
ONE OF THE THING I THINKS INTERM
PRESIDENT -- YOUEA JT
A FEW TIME YES, YES, I
E JUEDF HE
UNDERSTOIS TO REMAIN RSE WHEN, Y
SPEAK DIRECTLY ITH
MICROP
DIRECTLY AHEAD.
MEANORTH ENT REMINDEDE T OF
DURING THE PDES
WITHINN HING
TO GET UNDER HISKI
THAT'S THE HADHIS
AS HE SAT
E WITH HIS ATTORNEYSSOME DISCUS
START MO MORKLY. OBVIO JT BEEN O
ABLUICKLONE YOU SAIAMI.
AIIFERE WAT OF
ING BEEN IN THE
ONE IN MIAMI.
YOU COULD SEE HOW THIS O IS
ING TO UP
LOFFERENTLY.
GUYS?
>> Reporter: AND THAT'S
PEIKE TOIDE OOM WHERE T
UMJACK SMITH ARE I
R
ST B J HED IN OWHETHE NTRUMP S T
STS OR
>>orRIGHT.
SHE'S SAYING THAT
HIS APPEARANCE AND NOTAV NG NDF
HAVE TOLD GO THAY BEET
THE  SEVEN DAYS THEYTOFILE A BR
MUCH PREPARATION THEY NEED TO DO
R  TRIAL.
TH
IS IS MOVINGLOFASTNSE ATTORNEYS
TOO.
T ANSWERO THAT QUESTHOW MUKEROUT
QUOTE, SPEEDY TRIAL.
RNEYS, THE
TO DELAY THIAS LONG  P
THIS IS A PRETTY
TURNAROUND IN TERMS OFAN THIS AI